Stanford lies at the heart of Silicon
Valley and when you think of Silicon
Valley and by implication Stanford you
think of the people who take risks break
boundaries that's the reason why I think
Stanford indeed is a unique place to
understand innovation and
entrepreneurship we have cherry picked
to be honest the best Stanford faculty
we can find an entrepreneurship and
innovation on one hand you'll have
people who will do a more rigorous
research like my colleague huggy Rao on
the other hand you'll have folks like
Harry Clavin who actually invented the
modern snowshoe so we have that sort of
range of folks to bring together if you
will the rigorous and they're relevant
but would the certificate program and
the corpses in the certificate program
do is the inform people about
cutting-edge practices they illuminate
principles underlying innovation and
entrepreneurship but most of all they
inspire people so that you can go out
and innovate and be an entrepreneur in
your own company or in your own corner
of the world
taught by world-renowned faculty from
the Graduate School of Business and the
School of Engineering the Stanford
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate is a self-paced interactive
online program where you will gain
essential skills and effective
strategies to generate and implement new
ideas each course is divided into
modules and contains lectures
interactive assignments and readings
throughout the course the Stanford
teaching team will provide you with
feedback on select assignments
challenging you to apply your knowledge
and hone your innovation skills through
the forum you can deepen the learning
experience by discussing course topics
and interacting with your peers and the
Stanford teaching team upon the
successful completion of eight courses
you will receive your Stanford
certificate the question of how you lead
innovative work or contribute to it is
something that I just see as generic
problems in all organizations that try
to be effective
our hope is it's only the start of a
journey that individuals embark on a
journey where they will create companies
create products create services reshape
the big enterprises that they work in
you